in this book you've developed a
framework for how to fix everything
it's called the latter can you explain
it okay it's not a framework for how to
fix everything
I'll explain it to Tim Urban at some
point okay call this humor thing yeah
framework of uh how to think about
collaboration between humans such that
we could fix things I think it's a
compass it's like uh it's like a
it's a ruler that we can once we look at
it together and see what it is we can
all say oh we want to go to that side of
the ruler sure not this side
um and so it gives us a direction to go
and so what are the parts of the ladder
so I have these two characters this
orange guy this primitive mind is this
is our software that is the software
that was in a 50 000 BC person's head
that was specifically optimized for to
help that person survive in that world
and not even not just not really survive
but help them pass their genes on in
that world
um and
civilization happened quickly and brains
change slowly and so that unchanged dude
is still running the show in our head
um and I use the example of like
Skittles
like why do we eat Skittles it's trash
it's obviously bad for you and it's
because
the Primitive mind
in the world that it was programmed for
there was no Skittles and it was just
fruit and you know and and if there was
a dense chewy Sweet fruit like that it
meant you just found like a calorie Gold
Mine energy energy take it take it eat
as much as you can gorge on it hopefully
you get a little fat that would be the
dream and now we're so good with energy
for a while I don't have to stress about
it anymore so today Mars Inc is clever
and says let's not sell things to
people's higher Minds who's the other
character let's sell the people's
primitive Minds primitive minds are dumb
and let's trick them into thinking this
is this new this this thing you should
eat and then they'll eat it now Mars Inc
is a huge company actually it's just a
little real quick so you said primitive
mind and higher Minds so those are the
two things that make up
this bigger mind that it that is the
modern human being yeah it's like you
know it's not perfect obviously there's
a lot of crossover um there's people who
will yell at me for saying there's two
minds and you know that but to me it's
just still a useful framework where you
have this software that has making
decisions based on a world that you're
not in anymore and then you've got this
other character I call it the higher
mind and it's the part of you that knows
that skills are not good and can
override the Instinct and the reason you
don't always eat Skittles is because the
higher mind says no no no we're not
doing that because that's bad and I know
that right now you can apply that to a
lot of things the higher Minds the one
that knows I shouldn't procrastinate the
Primitive Minds the one that wants to
conserve energy and not do anything icky
and you know can't see the future so he
procrastinates that you know you can
apply this no I in this book apply it to
um
to how we form our beliefs is one of the
ways and then eventually the politics
and political movements but like
if you think about well what's the
equivalent of the Skittles tug of war in
your head for how do you form your
beliefs
um
and it's that the Primitive mind in the
world that it was optimized for
um it wanted to
feel conviction about its beliefs it
wanted to be sure that it was
um I wanted to feel conviction and it
wanted to agree with the people around
there didn't want to stand out and
wanted to to perfectly agree with the
tribe about the tribe's sacred beliefs
right and so there's a big part of us
that wants to do that that doesn't like
changing our mind it feels like it's
part of our the Primitive mind
identifies with beliefs feels like it's
a threat a physical threat to you to
your primitive mind when you change your
mind or when someone disagrees with you
in a smart way so there's that huge
force in us which is confirmation bias
that's where that comes from it's it's
this this desire to keep believing what
we believe and this desire to also fit
in with our beliefs to believe what the
people around us believe and that can be
fun in some ways we all like the same
sports team and we're all super into it
and we're all gonna be biased about that
call together I mean that it's not
always bad but um it's not a very smart
way to be and it you're actually you're
working kind of for those ideas those
ideas are like your boss and you're
working so hard to keep believing those
those ideas are you know a really good
paper comes in that you read that that
conflicts with those ideas and you will
do all this work to say that paper is
[__] because
you're a faithful employee of those
ideas now the higher mind to me the same
party that can override the Skittles can
override this and can and can search for
something that makes a lot more sense
which is Truth uh because what rational
being wouldn't want to know the truth
who wants to be delusional and so
there's this tug of war because the
higher mind doesn't identify with ideas
why would you it's an experiment you're
doing it's a mental model and if someone
can come over and say you're wrong you'd
say where show me show me and if they
point out something that is wrong and
say oh thanks oh good I just got a
little smarter right you're not going to
identify with the thing I'll go yeah
kick it see if you can break it if you
can break it it's not that good right so
there's both of these in our heads and
there's this tug of war between them uh
and sometimes you know if you're telling
me about something with AI I'm probably
gonna think with my higher mind because
I'm not identified with it but if you go
when you criticize the ideas in this
book or you criticize my religious
beliefs are you criticized I might have
a harder time because the Primitive mind
says no no those are our I special ideas
and so yeah so that's that's one way to
use this ladder is like it's a spectrum
you know at the top the higher mind is
doing all the thinking and then as you
go down it becomes more of a tug of war
and at the bottom the Primitive mind is
in total control and this is distinct as
you show from the spectrum of ideas so
this is how you think versus what you
think and those are distinct those are
different dimensions we need we need a
vertical axis we have all these
horizontal axes Left Right Center or you
know you know this opinion all the way
to this opinion but it's like
what's much more important than where
you stand is how you got there right and
how you think so this helps if if I can
say this person's kind of on the left or
on the right but they're up high I think
I think in other words I think they got
there using evidence and reason and they
were willing to change their mind now
that means a lot to me what they have to
say if I think they're just a tribal
person and I can predict all their
beliefs from hearing one because it's so
obvious what political beliefs that
person's views are irrelevant to me
because they're not real they didn't
come from information they came from a
tribe's kind of you know sacred Ten
Commandments I really like the comic you
have in here but with the boxer uh this
is the best boxer in the world wow cool
who has he beaten no one he's never
fought anyone then how do you know he's
the best boxer in the world I can just
tell now I mean this connects with me
and I think with a lot of people just
because in martial arts it's especially
kind of true that this is this whole
legend about different martial artists
and that kind of would construct like
action figures like you know thinking
that uh Steven Seagal is the best
fighter in the world or Chuck Norris But
Chuck Norris is actually backed up he's
done really well in competition but
still the ultimate test for particularly
for martial arts is what we now know is
uh mixed martial arts UFC and so on and
that's the actual scientific testing
ground some meritocracy yeah exactly I
mean there's within certain rules and
you can criticize those rules like this
doesn't actually represent the broader
combat that you would think of when
you're thinking about martial arts but
reality is you're actually testing
things and that's when you realize that
Aikido and some of these kind of woo-woo
martial arts in their certain
limitations don't work in the way you
think they would in the context of
fighting I think this is one of the
places where everyone can agree which is
why it's a really nice comic because
then you start to talk about
map this onto ideas that people take
personally it starts becoming a lot more
difficult to um
to basically highlight that we're
thinking with uh not with our higher
mind but with our primitive mind
yeah I mean if if I'm thinking with my
higher mind and now here is you can use
different things for an idea as a
metaphor so here the metaphor is a boxer
yeah
for and for one of your conclusions one
of your beliefs and
if I'm if I'm if I'm if all I care about
is truth and up in other words for the
that means all I care about is having a
good boxer
I would
say go go yeah try see if this person's
good go go I would in other words I
would get into arguments which is
throwing my boxer out there to fight
against other ones
um and if I think my argument's good by
the way I love boxing if I if I think my
guy is is amazing you know Mike Tyson
I'm thinking oh yeah bring it on who
wants to come see I bet no one can beat
my boxer I love a good debate right in
that case
now what would you think about my boxer
if not only had was I telling you he was
great but he's never boxed anyone but
then you said okay well your idea came
over to try to punch him and I screamed
and I said what are you doing that's
violence and you're you're in your and
you're an awful person and I don't want
to be friends with you anymore because
you you would think this boxer obviously
sucks or at least I think it sucks deep
down because uh why would I be so empty
anyone note boxing aloud you know people
so I I think
if you're in so this I call this a
ladder right if you're in low wrong land
you know whether it's a culture or
whatever a debate an argument when
someone says no that's totally wrong
uh what you're saying about that and
here's why you're actually being totally
biased
it sounds like a fight people are gonna
say oh wow we got in like a fight it was
really awkward like are we still friends
with that person because that's not a
culture or boxing it's a culture where
you don't touch each other's ideas
that's just it's insensitive versus and
and I in a you know a high rung culture
uh it's sport that's I mean look at
every one of your podcasts your your
agree whether you're agreeing or
disagreeing the tone is the same it's
not like oh this got awkward it's like
it's it's the tone is identical because
you're just playing intellectually
either way because it's a good high
wrong space at his best at his best but
people do take stuff personally and then
that's actually one of the skills of
conversation just as a fan of podcasts
is when you sense that people take a
thing personally you have to like
there's sort of methodologies and little
paths you can take to like calm things
down like go around don't don't take it
as a violation of like you're trying to
suss out which of their ideas are sacred
to them yeah and which ones are uh bring
it on and sometimes it's actually I mean
that's the skill of it I suppose that
sometimes it's a certain wordings
in the way you challenge those ideas are
important you can you can challenge them
indirectly and then together walk
together in that way because they're
what I've learned
is people are used
to their ideas being attacked in a
certain way in a certain Tribal Way and
if you just avoid those like for example
if you have political discussions and
just never mention left to right or a
Republican and Democrats none of that
just talk about different ideas and and
avoid certain kind of triggering words
you can actually talk about ideas versus
falling into this
path that's well established through
battles that people have previously
fought when you say triggering I mean
who's getting triggered the Primitive
mind so what you're trying to do what
you're saying in this language is how do
you have conversations with other
people's higher Minds almost like
Whispering without waking up The
Primitives Criminal Mind as they're
sleeping right and as soon as you say as
soon as you say something the left
primary mind gets up and says what what
are you saying about the left and now
now that everything goes off the rails
uh what do you make of conspiracy
theories under this framework of the
latter so
here's the thing about conspiracy
theories is that
once in a while they're true right
because sometimes there's a natural
conspiracy actually humans are pretty
good at real conspiracies secret things
uh and then you know I just watched the
maid off doc
um great new Netflix stock by the way
um and
um so the question is
how do you create a system that is good
at you put the conspiracy theory in and
it either goes e or it says this is
interesting let's keep exploring it like
how do you put how do you do something
that it can how do you assess and so
again I think the hiron culture
is really good at it because a real
conspiracy what's going to happen is you
put it it's like a little machine you
put in the middle of the table and
everyone starts firing darts at it or
bow and arrow or whatever and everyone
starts kicking it and trying to
and almost all conspiracy theories they
quickly crumble right because they
actually you know you know Trump's
election one is and I actually dug in
and I looked at like every claim that he
or his team made and I was like
all of these none of these hold up to
scrutiny none of them I was open-minded
but none of them did so that was one
that as soon as it's open to scrutiny it
crumbles
the only way that conspiracy can stick
around in a community is if
it is a culture where that's being
treated as a sacred idea that no one
should kick or throw a dart at because
if you throw a dart it's going to break
so it's being it's and so what you want
is a is a culture where no idea is
sacred anything can get thrown out and
so I think that then what you'll find is
that 994 out of 100 conspiracy theories
come in and they fall down the other
maybe four of the others come in and
there's something there but it's not as
Extreme as people say and then maybe one
is a huge deal and it's actually a real
conspiracy well isn't there a lot of
gray area and there's a lot of mystery
isn't that where the conspiracy theories
seep in so uh it's great to hear that
you've really looked into the the Trump
election fraud claims
but aren't they resting on a lot of kind
of gray area like fog basically saying
that there is dark Forces in the shadows
that are actually controlling everything
I mean the same thing with uh maybe you
can there's like safer conspiracy
theories more less controversial ones
like have we landed on the moon right
did the United States ever land on the
Moon
there's you know you like the reason
those conspiracy theories work is you
could construct there's incentives and
motivation for faking the moon landing
there's a lot of
um there's a there's very little data
supporting the moon landing like that's
very public and kind of looks fake space
that would be a big story if it turned
out to be fake that's the art that's
that would be the argument against it
like our people really is a collective
going to hold on to a story that big
um yeah so that but but there's a lot
that the reason they work is there's
mystery yeah it's a great documentary
called behind the curve about flat
earthers and one of the things that you
learn about flat earthers is they
believe
all the conspiracies not just the Flat
Earth they're they're convinced the moon
landing is fake they're convinced 911
was an American con job
they're convinced you know that name a
conspiracy and they believe it and so
it's so interesting is that
I think of it as a um
as a skepticism Spectrum yeah so on one
side you it's like a filter in your head
a filter in your in the beliefs section
of your brain on one end of the spectrum
you are gullible perfectly gullible you
believe anything someone says right on
the other side you're paranoid you think
everyone's lying to you right
everything's everything is false nothing
that anyone says is true right so
obviously those aren't good places to be
um now the healthy place I think that
that the so so I think the healthy place
is to be somewhere in the middle and but
also you can learn to trust certain
sources and then you know you don't have
to do as much apply as much skepticism
to them and so here's what
like and when you start having a bias
just so you have a political bias
when your side says something you you
will find yourself moving towards the
gullible side of the spectrum you read
an article written that's that supports
your views you move to the gullible side
of the spectrum and you just believe it
you don't have any where's that
skepticism that you normally have right
and then you move and then you soon as
soon as it's the other person talking
the other team talking you move to the
skeptical the the closer to the to the
you know denial paranoid side now
flat earthers are the extreme they are
either at 10 or 1.
so it's like it's so interesting because
they're the people who are saying ah nah
I won't believe you I'm not gullible no
everyone else is gullible about the moon
landing I won't and then yet when
there's this evidence like oh because
you can't see Seattle you can't see the
buildings over that Horizon and you
should which isn't true you should be if
it were or if the Earth around you
wouldn't be able to see them therefore
it's so suddenly they become the most
gullible person here any theory about
the earth flat they believe it it goes
right into their beliefs so they're
actually jumping back and forth between
refuses to believe anything and believe
anything and so they're the extreme
example but I think when it comes to
conspiracy theories the people that get
themselves into trouble
are the ones who they they become really
gullible when they hear a conspiracy
theory that kind of fits with their
world view and they likewise when
there's something that's kind of
obviously true and it's not a big lie
they will actually uh they'll they'll
think it is they they just tighten up
their kind of skepticism filter and and
so yeah so I I think the healthy places
to be is where you are not because you
also don't want to be the person who
says every conspiracy you hear the word
conspiracy theory and it sounds like a
like a synonym for like quack job crazy
Theory right so yeah so I I think yeah I
think it's be somewhere in the middle of
that spectrum and to learn to fine tune
it which is a tricky place to operate
because you kind of have to every time
you hear a new conspiracy theory you
should approach it with an open mind
and you know and also if you don't have
enough time to investigate which most
people don't kind of still have a
humility not to make a conclusive
statement that that's nonsense there's a
lot of um social pressure actually yeah
to immediately laugh off any conspiracy
theory if it's done by the the bad guys
right you will quickly get mocked and
laughed at and not taken seriously if
you give any Credence you know back the
lab leak was it was a good one where
it's like uh turned out that that was at
least very credible if not true and
that was a perfect example of one where
when it first came out any not only so
so Brett Weinstein talked about it and
then I in a totally different
conversation said something
complimentary about him on a totally
different subject
and people were saying Tim you might
have gone a little off the deep end
you're like quoting someone who is like
a lab leak person so I was getting my
reputation dinged
for complimenting on a different topic
someone whose reputation was totally
sullied because they have you know they
questioned an Orthodoxy right so it's
you see in so what does that make me
want to do distance myself from Brett
Weinstein that's the at least they see
incentive that's uh and what does that
make other people want to do don't
become the next Brit Weinstein don't say
it out loud because you don't want to
become someone that no one wants to
compliment anymore right you can see the
social pressure and that's and of course
when there is a conspiracy that social
pressure is its best friend
because then they see the people from
outside are seeing that social pressure
enact like a Tim Urban becoming more and
more and more extreme to the other side
and so they're going to take the more
and more and more extreme I mean this
what what do you see that the pandemic
did
that kova did to our civilization in
that regard in the forces why was it so
divisive do you understand that
yeah so covert I you know I thought
might be you know we always you know the
ultimate example of the topic that will
unite us all is the alien attack yeah
although honestly I don't even have that
much Faith then I think there'd be like
some people are super like you know
pro-alien and some people aren't the
alien but anyway I was like a sergeant
to interrupt because I was talking to a
few
um astronomers and they they're the
first
folks that
maybe kind of sad in that if we discover
Life on Mars for example
that there's going to be potentially a
division over that too where half the
people will not believe that's real
well because
we we live in a current Society where
the political divide
has subsumed everything and that's not
always like that uh it goes into stages
like that we're in a really bad one
where it's I actually in the the book I
call it like a Vortex like a like a like
a almost like a Whirlpool that pulls
everything into it it pulls it pulls um
and so normally you'd say okay you know
immigration naturally going to be
contentious that's always political
right yeah but like
covid seemed like oh that's one of those
that will unite us all let's fight this
not human virus thing like obvious is no
no one's sensitive no one's like getting
hurt when we insult the virus like let's
all be we have this threat it's common
threat that's a threat to everyone of
every nationality in every country every
ethnicity and
and what it didn't do that at all the
whirlpool was too powerful so it pulled
coveted in and suddenly masks
if you're on the left you like them if
you're on the right you hate them and
suddenly lockdowns if you're on the left
you like them and on the right you hate
them and vaccines this is people who
forget this when when Trump first
started talking about the vaccine
Biden Harris
Cuomo they're all saying I'm not taking
that vaccine not from this CDC because I
was too rushed or something like that
but because I'm not trusting anything
that Trump says Trump wants me to take
it I'm not taking it I'm not taking it
from this CDC so
this was if Trump this Trump was almost
out of office but at the time if Trump
had been it would have been I'm pretty
sure it would have stayed Wright likes
vaccines the left blood doesn't like
vaccines instead the president switched
and all those people are suddenly saying
they were actually specifically saying
that if you you know that that like if
if you're saying the CDC is not
trustworthy that's misinformation which
is exactly what they were saying about
the other CDC and they were saying it
because they genuinely didn't trust
Trump which is fair but now when other
people don't trust the Biden CDC
Suddenly It's this kind of
misinformation that needs to be censored
so it was a sad moment because it was a
couple months at the very even a week or
so the I mean a month or so at the very
beginning when
it felt like a lot of our other
squabbles were kind of like oh I feel
like they're kind of irrelevant right
now yeah and then very quickly the
whirlpool sucked it in and and
in a way where I think it damaged the
reputation of these a lot of the the
Trust In A lot of these institutions for
the long run but there's also an
individual psychological impact it's
like a vicious negative feedback cycle
where they were deeply affected on an
emotional level and people just were not
their best cells
that's definitely true yeah I mean
talk about the Primitive mind I mean
what one thing that we've been dealing
with for our whole human history is
pathogens yeah and it's it's emotional
right it it brings out you know there's
really interesting studies where like
if they they studied the the the the
phenomenon of disgust which is one of
these like
have you know smiling is universal you
don't have to ever translate a smile
right certain you know you know throwing
your hands up when you're when your
sports team wins it's Universal because
it's part of our we're coding and so is
disgust to kind of make this like you
know face where you wrinkle up your nose
and you kind of put out your tongue and
maybe even gag that's to expel expel
whatever's because it's It's the
reaction when something is potentially a
pathogen that might harm us right feces
vomit whatever
but they did this interesting study
where people
who in in two two groups the control
group you know was shown images of
um in my beginning two studies mixed up
but they were showing they were showing
images of like car crashes and like
disturbing but not disgusting and the
other one was showing like you know like
you know rotting things and just just
things that were disgusting and then
they were asked about immigration these
were Canadians and the group that was
had the disgust feeling going pulsing
through their body was way more likely
to prefer like immigrants from White
countries
and the group that was had been showing
car accidents they were they still
preferred the groups from White
countries but much less so and so what
what does that mean it's because with
the disgust impulse makes us scared of
you know sexual practices that are
foreign of ethnicities that are not look
that don't look like us of of it's still
xenophobia so it's ugly it's this really
ugly stuff this is of course also how
you know the the Nazi propaganda with
cockroaches and uh or it was uh Rwandan
was cockroaches you know the Nazis was
rats and you know
it's it's specifically it's a
dehumanizing emotion so
anyway we were we were we were talking
about
um covid but I think it does it Taps
deep into like the human psyche in it
and it's I don't think it brings out our
I think like you said I think it brings
out an ugly side in US